[Music]
stanford university
today's session is on the race for
technological supremacy emerging
technologies and global applications
i'll start by letting the panelists
introduce themselves matt do you want to
kick us off
sure i'm matt sheehan i grew up in palo
alto primarily went to stanford
but since graduating back in 2010 i've
largely worked on u.s china issues and
now most recently on u.s china
technology so i lived in china 2010 to
2016. i came back i wrote a book about
china california sort of cooperation and
competition called the trans-pacific
experiment
and then since publishing that book i've
really dove into the technology aspect
of that so i primarily focus on u.s
china competition and interaction in
artificial intelligence at i work at
think tank carlson institute
graham do you want to go next
sure so i'm graham webster i'm a
researcher at the freeman spogli
institute at stanford and in the cyber
policy center
i lead a project called digichina which
studies chinese tech policy we do a lot
of translating and trying to explain
various chinese tech especially digital
but other technologies as well
by way of background i started as a
journalist and have lived in china a
couple of times did a whole kind of arc
where i began as a general sort of tech
in china journalist and then came back
for grad school and ended up doing kind
of comprehensive u.s china relations for
a few years all kinds of issues economic
military etc and then about three four
years ago i got back to my interest in
tech and politics and we started
building this project so that's for
those of you who are quote unquote on
campus we feel free to be in touch we
like to work with
other folks who are around
and last but not least seeing do you
want to go sure my name is ian david fan
i'm the head of digital trade the world
economic forum center for the fourth
industrial revolution we're based in the
presidio uh on the northern end of san
francisco and i also teach our course
product technology policy at the
berkeley goldman scope of public policy
lawyer by training also has a china
background
just like the two other panelists that's
how i worked at the law firm and the us
government on trade and also
before i joined a forum i helped airbnb
to enter china i think um from your
work with the world economic forum and i
know you're not
uh supposed to represent them on this
panel
strictly personal
at a high level how do you think society
will change due to new emerging
technologies we're seeing i know that
one of the forums focuses is of course
the fourth industrial revolution anne
could you talk a little bit more about
how
these new technologies will shape and
change society
yeah just very quickly you know what we
do here at the forum and it's something
i really believe in as well is that
new emerging technologies right ai
blockchain 5g just name your pick
technology is moving too fast for policy
regulations and there's a big gap in
between and that's the case all over the
world and it doesn't matter it's the u.s
and china as ghana
it's argentina
and that's a challenge that is both the
private sector and the public sector
space all right and why do i mean by
that is that in at least three aspects
right in the speed this
scope and the skills technologies are
changing too fast so just give some
quick examples right i think speed i
think you mentioned we have a former
current chess champion here right now
how the ibm machine
the world's chess champion back in 97
right direction champion and then in 19
uh
fast forward to 2016
16 was when alpha gold beat the world's
gold champion and that's a huge leap
right from beating chess which is by
brutal computation to beating the gold
champion and now in a year since ai can
now beat
the best starcraft players in the world
so i think it's just one quick example
to show how the speed of technology and
what i mean by scope is the that it's
not just a digital within the digital
realm however the digital physical and
biological or fusion i think we have
some engineering or tech medical
students here we'll know how crisper and
implications of society and lastly skill
industries don't technology don't just
stay in one neat bunch by working uh
digital trade
however i have a project in 3d printing
because i'm looking at the impact of 3d
printing on manufacturing and a global
trade and now an energy consumption
right all that all those are are related
so those are just some three really
quick examples and aspects to show that
technology is moving really fast and
same time policies regulations and all
societal norms are not keeping up and a
lot of things that we'll be discussing
today and i know when personally for
example the privacy issues etc etc are
examples of that gap and i think that's
we really need both the public and
private sector not just the tech the
tech folks we want to talk about the
private sector it's really all all the
different stakeholders to get together
and find a solution for it and that's
what we do unless at least what i do uh
on a daily basis
and question for any of the panelists is
we're hearing so much priority focused
on ai robotics 5g a lot of these
emerging technologies become a national
priority for a number of countries why
is ramping up research and development
funding on these emerging technologies
important for countries in the first
place
okay yeah i'll give it a shot i think
matt probably has some useful things to
say about this having he's done some
great research looking at the national
efforts in china and comparing
especially in ai fields what what the
two countries the economies have to
offer but i'll say as a sort of you know
economic and national security policy
priority
especially when it comes to the united
states and china there's a sense that
there is an advantage to be had
economically and in terms of national
security in being a
uh having within your your country
networks of innovators meaning that from
primary research to implementing and
marketing on
new technologies that aren't widely
deployed and there are a bunch of
reasons you can understand why there's a
lot of money to be made if 5g is the
great example if if huawei is really
building the kit that is for the world
in terms of performance then that's a
lot of money to be made and they end up
setting a lot of standards and even have
a lot of licensing fees to collect and
that only runs up against national
security concerns but in other fields
it's just a similar logic if you're
if your clusters of companies and
universities and other researchers and
national supported experimental zones
for instance allow companies within your
your country to become
leaders in automated avs or other things
that need a whole build out in part of a
city for instance that can it can just
be a huge advantage and the last thing
i'll say is that there is a national
security element to the extent that
there are both
vulnerabilities and capabilities that
come with advanced technologies getting
ahead can be
frankly a weakness and a strength but
national security organizations in many
countries are interested in making sure
that they're resilient to
attacks of various kinds that would be
fueled by automated technologies
and that they are using automation in
ways that reduce
cost and risk to service members in an
armed conflict not to mention this the
whole sort of back and forth of using um
machine learning in cyber security
offensive and defensive operations
there's a need to have if you're going
to run a big economy and a big national
security operation there's a need to
have relatively leading resources that
you can touch on and
if you're in a rivalry with one of the
countries that has those resources you
might lose access to them and that's
what we've seen happen over the last
couple of years with the us and china
primarily from the u.s side cutting off
chinese companies from from key supplies
and imperiling their high-tech
operations but that can go in the other
direction and in many other directions
with other countries matt what are your
thoughts um particularly haven't written
extensively on the topic including a
book about how china and california both
collaborate and compete for our
future yeah i think maybe i'll focus on
one slice of it which is just one that i
happens to be like top of mind right now
for me which is specifically why do
governments actually need to get
involved in this process and i think
most people agreed that like the
internet was a transformative technology
and the us gained a lot from being a
first mover in like building large
digital platforms
but if we can from maybe the night late
1980s onward from when the internet got
commercialized up through the present
day more or less that was primarily
funded and developed in the private
sector the very early routes were very
much out of us government funding from
like the darpa the defense advanced
research project
something a
and so i guess yeah my focus would be on
why is the government to get involved
and i think
throughout the 90s and 2000s and 2010s a
lot of us got lulled into a
belief
that you know drinking our own kool-aid
on just how
powerful the private sector is and just
the fact that we need to leave silicon
valley we need to leave technologists
entirely alone and that not interfering
not funding not distorting the market is
a crucial ingredient freedom is like the
most important ingredient to flourishing
in technology i think a lot of what the
last 10 years have been is a slow
undermining of that assumption and
the slow realization dawning on us that
actually the u.s government to for
specifically for technologies like ai
and 5g the us government kind of needs
to play a very active role
i think maybe half of that realization
came just watching how china has
developed over the last couple decades
and recognizing that concrete government
initiatives to expand stem education to
deploy ai across the economy to have the
government invest subsidize ai companies
subsidize ai talent to return from
overseas
and be a large like customer of ai
technology especially surveillance
technology recognizing that was in one
thing one way that china caught up
rather quickly that the government
played a pretty substantial role in that
and
i think it's conjured up a little bit of
insecurity on the u.s side some of which
is maybe overblown
rampant fear that china is going to
overtake us any day but the other part
of is just realistic that for a
technology like the internet the vast
number of commercial applications really
do not need public money involved in it
a company like uber a company like
airbnb a company like google can really
it's just information it's largely
information passing back and forth and
this is something that's primed for
funding by venture capital but for a lot
of the more like socially impactful
applications of ai especially the ones
that touch on national security like
what graham was referring to
those they need they need government
support if you're going to for example
roll out a sort of a fully autonomous
fleet throughout society fully
autonomous vehicle fleet throughout
society the government at the very least
needs to be very involved in the
regulatory side of that and in some
cases the government might need to
revamp public infrastructure to whether
that's putting sensors in the road or
just designing sort of street signage
and whatnot so that it's more
sort of machine readable and stuff like
that
and i just i'm in this u.s government
involvement headspace right now because
i just finished reading this very long
report from the national security
commission on ai independent us
government body and i'd say the biggest
kind of takeaway from that a group
that's sort of co-chaired by eric
schmidt and by leading people from dod
and elsewhere the biggest takeaway they
had is that the us government just needs
to get much more involved in technology
development and technology strategy
domestically not five-year plans and
state takeovers of private companies or
something like that
but guidance
sort of subsidies really doubling down
on funding of cutting-edge research
and a whole bunch of other mechanisms so
i think yeah that change in both the us
position vis-a-vis china and that change
in what the technology itself does and
can do are the two reasons why we're
seeing governments
kind of
step back onto the technology stage in a
way that sometimes they haven't since
the
cold war era
i'm glad you mentioned that report since
i have a few questions related to that
later today
but first i think a lot of people will
compare the approach of the united
states to be different from that of
china which is then different from out
of europe and that of other countries
would love for one of you to elaborate
just at a very high level how these
different approaches um differ and what
it might mean for the pace of r d
development and the pace of development
of these emerging technologies over the
next few years
i can take a crack at it but first i
just want to follow up on what matt said
and i totally agree i'm policymaking
aspect of it we work closely with the
private sector and i
personally hear a lot from the private
sector folks that
it's interesting right if you ask them
5-10 years ago especially the tech folks
i think some of them will say we are
just a tech company we're just a
platform we're just a software company
we don't get involved in policymaking we
don't need help or just let us be but
things have definitely changed in the
past 10 years and particularly in the
five years right and i think even now
some of the tech companies publicly
asked and say that we want
good regulation and i think some of the
ceo has stated that public we want good
regulation and maybe they're feeling
more pressure right so they want more
clear guidance and rules but also that
in many ways technology can only go so
far without reforming the policy and
government space for example to give a
concrete example in trade
standardization uh
for example data is a major issue
harmonization of different countries
different regional state standards and
that's the issue that yeah private
sector can push but definitely we need
public sector and the policy support and
to answer a question i think if we look
at this is a huge generalization so i'll
make this
disclaimer like this big you know if you
look at the us and china i'll again
fusion or exactly i'll say the us is
more market driven
you can see it called a value driven and
china may be more government or state
driven a lot of exceptions on that but i
think
generally speaking the u.s take this you
know taking privacy as example rice i
don't have a federal uh privacy law
california has a state one but you know
generally things are okay unless you do
something wrong then ftc comes and stuff
over here whereas you obviously with the
gdpr yeah i think there's a high level i
think those are some of the distinctions
of course there are a lot of exceptions
to to that and of course that also
creates generally speaking different
attitudes and ecosystem within the uh
each country which elaborate more but
i'll pass over to other panelists
any
yeah one quick thought on the europe
side of it i think
just a few years ago
everyone's very focused obviously on the
u.s china dynamic of this and those are
the two countries that are putting out
the strongest companies and in many ways
producing like the top-tier research i
think just a few years ago there was a
real kind of at least in the u.s there's
a real rolling of eyes at the idea that
europe could become a major player in ai
through
sort of government regulation in a lot
of ways but i think yeah again in this
time period sort of 2015 to 2020
europe has proven that when you have a
market that large
and you're willing to set draconian
rules or obligations on tech companies
they really will come to heal for you
they will amend their you know content
moderation policies they will
amend their data privacy policies with
you know gdpr
so just as a comment because i think
many in the us and me sometimes in the
past have felt this kind of oh like
europe just can't really produce the
technology but wants to govern
everybody's technology but i think
my perception on that front has shifted
substantially that i think that kind of
value
xiang referred to it as a value driven
approach i think of it i just tweaked it
slightly to say like a regulatory driven
approach but regulations driven by
values yeah i think it's more powerful
than we had imagined in in past years
and do you any of you think there is a
first mover advantage to being the first
in terms of being an ai leader or a 5g
leader or a robotics leader is there a
first mover advantage and are countries
like europe who might be considered
falling behind on
the development of these technologies at
a significant disadvantage
so maybe i'll take that first and i
promise to before when we were talking
before i promised to challenge a little
bit the frame of ai or whatever type of
tech supremacy and and i think that it's
useful to disaggregate a little bit the
notion of leadership and i think that i
think there's definitely first mover
advantage for firms there's first mover
advantage for sort of networks of
people who develop the primary research
and then market it and then deploy it
but you really have to look technology
by technology and the first mover
advantage is somewhat less on things
that are really primary research that
simply get published in
public papers and then can be
implemented around the world and then
maybe you don't have the first mover
advantage when you've come up with the
new machine learning algorithm until
somebody else comes up with the chip
that runs at great efficiency there's
it's going to be a networked type of
advantage and i think rarely we will
find
broad areas of technology where a
national advantage or supremacy is a
reasonable way to look at it i think
that
unless frankly the us and china and some
other countries but primarily them and
maybe india continue the process of
trying to wall themselves off from one
another technologically if we go further
down that road there might be more of a
kind of distinct mutually exclusive set
of tech ecosystems where some things
will be broadly more advanced in one
place than at another at the moment
we're still fairly interlinked and most
advantages that you would accrue to a
chinese firm or a us firm are actually
frankly going to be depending on inputs
whether in terms of intellectual
property labor physical parts or
licensed ip from one another and from
many other countries so that's my kind
of did it deny the premise of the
question thing but i will say again on
military things there's obviously
technological supremacy when you're
having a dog fight with fighter
some planes are going to be able to
maneuver better and if you have none if
you have unmanned vehicles that are able
to maneuver
at g-forces that are not survivable by
humans flying airplanes then they're
going to be better at shooting down
fighter jets and so they're in in really
state-to-state competitive frames like
military conflict it is more reasonable
to talk about supremacy or dominance or
advantage than others i tend to find it
to be distracting from
the policy challenges that
should be pursued which includes some of
the things we've been talking about both
so young and matt you know mentioned
different approaches i think that
there are different policy challenges in
each country and they all have to do
with solving
conflicts of power relations between
sectors of society or parts of the
government or and their relations with
various firms and industries and foreign
domestic so it ends up being like all of
our supply chains very networked in
terms of who's actually winning we
started to talk a little bit today about
approaches by different countries and
there is some need to explore
technology through this military lens
the next question we have is around some
conversations that have occurred where
some have proposed that the us
established an emerging technology
coalition with allies and just thinking
about should countries be working
together how should the u.s work with
allies and partners and i asked this
question um not because
the idea of ai enabled warfare is
the first move that anyone wants to do
but
whenever there's new technology it
almost always comes with some sort of
pursuit of power and countries might be
forced into the prospect of ai enabled
warfare just based on choices made by
their strategic competitors and how
should we think about exploring ai
through that military lens concepts like
ai enabled autonomous operations how
should we think about countries working
together and we can start with just the
us being one example of how the us
should work with its allies and partners
in in my heart i'm always with graham on
the interconnections the networks and
stuff like that but i've learned to
speak through a little more zero-sum
competition game
in terms of kind of the two you have two
parts of that the coalition question how
should we work together in coalitions
and also the kind of ai in warfare
question i think at least at this point
those are still those are like different
initiatives i think the us is very
focused on building out sort of
coalition partners but i think that's
primarily for the purpose of shaping the
marketplace shaping the values around
how technology is deployed and making
yeah making more countries likely to end
up coming on board with say a broad like
u.s european set of technologies
one example of it that it a lot of this
attention gets deflected to southeast
asia and south asia and say this is a
major sort of competition ground for the
us and china
in whether it's like platform apps tick
tock versus youtube or whatever the
instagram whatever that competition is
and i think there is there's a sense
in the us that if we don't if we don't
put up
barriers or incentives for countries to
largely adopt the u.s technology stack
as opposed to the chinese technology
stack
it's going to
a lot of those countries are going to
end up sliding into sort of the chinese
camp because china tends to be
through something like a belt and road
initiative or through like broader
infrastructure
projects down there they see a major
sort of strategic and advantage in
having say huawei build out the 5g
networks in places like that in europe
too but i think we feel a little more
secure in europe so i think a lot of the
we we're worried about that in the us
from a market share standpoint saying we
whatever we want our technology
companies to be the one that are
profiting off a billion new people
coming online and shopping but the way
that we i think a lot of times bring on
europe and get into this kind of
coalition mindset is by putting that
like values layer over the top say if
you buy say a smart city package from
alibaba which is something that alibaba
does market around the world if you buy
that smart city package at the end of
the day that's going to say bolster
potentially like anti-democratic
forces within societies maybe throughout
southeast asia
and we want to have an intervention to
stop that and this is where i think
we're finding some common ground with
europe i think when it comes to the kind
of
the more tactical aspects of the us just
saying hey we need to beat china in a
market sense or in a technology sense
hey europe jump on board with us on this
i think they're a lot more hesitant than
we might believe the one area europe has
big issues with u.s technology companies
and they're constantly taking taking u.s
companies to task for this and so i
think the us in many ways wants to use
the
the values driven lens holding up china
as a paragon of a kind of totalitarian
surveillance state using that as a lens
to get
europe and maybe some other europe japan
uh south korea and then india is usually
like the more developing country that's
usually thrown in the mix we want to use
that
values-driven coalition lens as a way to
to keep china out of more foreign
markets that's a slightly more cynical
approach there are genuine like very
real concerns here but i do see a a
convenient sort of intersection between
those uh values-driven approaches and
what we just want from a competitive
standpoint
i do want to talk about the
misinformation campaigns that have
deployed fake content on social networks
that have then been used to influence
democratic elections in the us and
europe and just the whole idea of the
increased use of ai by foreign powers to
spread disinformation online and launch
cyber attacks
what should we be doing to guard against
these threats is this an approach that
we need the private sector to be taking
an active role in or should we be
leading up to policy maybe xengol i'll
throw that question over to you
yeah the forum is the organization for
public and private partnership so i'll
definitely advocate for that forever to
decide to work together just on that i
think it obviously is a tremendously uh
uh serious question and
there are tech solutions and there are
policy solutions and the ideal is that
we can do both and combine both
solutions i i
personally think that's something we
can't address this is a serious issue i
think what's interesting to
to know and to look at this issue is
that how from the both sides right from
the the tax company side and the policy
side they're trying to move things
forward facebook we have you know you
probably heard this supreme court of
facebook which i think it you know it's
definitely a step in the right direction
but also raises a lot of questions and
folks are asking questions like who gets
to sit on on this court uh a supreme
court and what if you disagree with that
decision and can we allow a company to
make that kind of decision uh some folks
argue it should be more like a pallet
court instead of a supreme court so i
think maybe we'll take one step back
having worked in both the public and
private sector i think we
absolutely need more folks in the
government to be more tech savvy and
more folks in the tech sector to be
mindful of policy implications i think a
lot of the mess that we are in today is
because there's lack of both people on
both sides and for example maybe some
folks in that on the tech side just
didn't you know think too far or didn't
think uh in a very comprehensive way of
how this technology will lead to certain
impacts and implications where maybe
focus too much a bit just on the tech
side which is maybe not not to their
fault at all given their uh
responsibilities
engineer coders etc so i think it's this
awareness building the tech side and the
knowledge building on the on the policy
side so we
the more familiarity understanding of
how technology work and not just either
past knee-jerk reactions i need european
policies or just ignore it all together
i think that's really the way we can
move forward
i'm curious um if others have thoughts
on this and part of the reason why i
also asked this question around guarding
against um these sorts of ai threats is
i think for the first time we're seeing
ai attacks that are being based not
because most traditional cyber attacks
are usually because there's bugs or
loopholes or some sort of human mistakes
in the code but these ai attacks that
we've seen more recently it's just based
on inherent limitations in the
algorithms that currently cannot be
fixed so just very curious on your
thoughts in terms of what should we be
doing to guard against these sorts of
threats
yeah i have a few thoughts on this and
part of it i think it
to some extent it helps illuminate some
of the challenges in something like us
europe and maybe others
tech alliance of democracies because
there's a
there's a fundamental disconnect in
terms of how you would handle
disinformation or sort of algorithmic
manipulation in a european regulatory
framework versus an american framework
and it's possible the united states will
later have a national privacy framework
or a law it's possible that it's that
tim wu is going into the white house and
lina khan is is being nominated for the
ftc it's the anti-trust uh anti-tech
anti-trust forces are gathering in
washington and i think that portends
some fairly significant changes that may
need to happen in various companies but
for now there isn't alignment because
then in the u.s framework we've been
just it's a little bit whack-a-mole it's
holy
the russians might have tipped the
election
using
various means including cambridge
analytica and dated maybe we don't know
but
wow and then let's
let's all panic about this for four
years and then see if we can't get
everyone worked up about not having the
election be messed up and then the
post-mortem on that is
the jury's out there's there's been some
good events from the
from our cyber policy center colleagues
looking at that and a lot of my
colleagues were working very hard on uh
day-to-day monitoring disinformation but
it's basically a laissez-faire solution
wait for
harm to
rear its head and then
use power relationships to essentially
try to force the harm to go away but
that doesn't help for countries that
don't have that much power over the
american tech giants or the chinese tech
giants that whose services they may be
using the
it may not be a super popular opinion
around silicon valley is that's what
i've found so far but i think there's a
real dilemma to be wrestled with around
the business model of
companies that operate in the
information space and it's well
summed up in the
the long argument by shoshana zubov
about surveillance capitalism and how
essentially the business model of the
various social media companies depends
on
selling persuasion and selling
manipulation of the users to any bidder
that is authorized and i think there's a
real argument to be made that's a little
more european compatible and frankly a
bit more
chinese digital economy compatible in
terms of regulation to say that this
type of manipulation should not be
something that you're selling find a
different business model so from the
perspective of innovation and kind of
business
people and people who might be designing
products i think it would be really
powerful if there was a
whether it's policy or industry led i
would probably be more successful if it
was in industry led to to think about
how to provide
compelling products and services that
do not depend on this
particular type of manipulation for pay
which would essentially remove the kind
of in one of the major avenues for
intentional manipulation right there
would still be accidental cascades and
some model ends up shoving people over
in the youtube algorithm that gets
people to watch the the extremist
content that's just optim optimizing a
product for engagement and keeping
people involved fine but
if there are ways to go about trying to
build this risk out of the business
model i think that would be really
powerful and it would require serious
serious new work right it wouldn't be
continuous with the way that things are
done right now at the big companies in
silicon valley and i hope people are
working on
yeah the the national security
commission on ai and the report that
matt alluded to earlier does touch a
little bit upon these misinformation
campaigns specifically to pull a quote
from the report it states that ai is
deepening the threat posed by cyber
attacks and disinformation campaigns
that russia china and others are using
to infiltrate our society steal our data
and interfere in our democracy the
limited uses of ai enable attacks to
date represent the tip of the iceberg so
they define this as the tip of the
iceberg question i have for all of you
is should we be setting policy to allow
people to report
any sort of irresponsible ai deployment
any sort of ai enabled attack or is that
even possible to set some sort of policy
to report that
i
don't know would be the short answer i
there there are companies uh not
companies but organizations out there
that are basically trying to catalog
incidents of either like malign uses of
ai
or
unsafe which i guess you could cross
over to irresponsible deployments of ai
and basically build a sort of a catalog
around these things
the i especially when it comes to
disinformation this is going to just be
this is going to be happening on a scope
and a scale that we can't i don't think
can be manually countered or or
documented in that way
but i think the the sort of the safety
element of some of it is something that
i i spend a fair amount of time looking
at this is not safety in regards to
distance information or misinformation
it's safety in regards to the
brittleness we often use that term
brittleness of ai systems and this is
maybe what ernestine was referring to
earlier where it's not a
bug in the code or something like that
but adversarial attacks i think one area
we've been now
almost a decade of rapid progress in
sort of the performance of ai systems
and therefore wanting to basically throw
these systems at more and more uh
problems throughout society
so it started with kind of very
i was about to call them low stakes but
maybe with all this misinformation talk
it's not right to call advertising a low
stakes game but the low-hanging fruit of
the ai revolution was or machine
learning ai broadly speaking was to
basically opt to you know optimize based
on a data set optimize recommendations
based on a large training set and so
that kind of diffused throughout the
technology companies first
and then we started applying it to
financial markets and insurance markets
and again not there are consequences for
that but maybe a little bit more
contained and i think where we're headed
next and where a lot of the
organizations who focus on like
cataloging these incidents are focused
is on
broad safety concerns from uh
functionally ai mis-optimizing or
misfiring in the real world
and
this is called i'm like starting down
this path i'm like oh no this is gonna
we're gonna take way too long to try to
like document this basically what i
think we have not put a sufficient
attention into is looking at safety of
ai systems for like mission critical
deployment there was a recent study from
the
center for security and emerging
technology at georgetown where they
compare the performance of
standard ai systems leading algorithms
at certain tasks with the sort of level
of performance we require from the
systems for running like autopilot on an
airplane or something like that
and we've gotten i think the the result
was that our ai systems are nowhere near
the level of kind of verifiable safety
critical
performance that we require from like
big real world systems things that
control real world items and i think
we're hopefully at this turning point
where we can we're very excited about ai
it's going to change everything it's
going to transform everything getting
made better with it etc etc recognizing
just how brittle these systems can be
when they're deployed in the wild a lot
of the most dramatic improvements are
happening in uh
like laboratory testing against
benchmarks but if we were to deploy
these in the most the next form is
probably going to be autonomous vehicles
on a broad scale i think we haven't
quite grappled with how how brettable
how brittle and how easy it is to break
these systems
so i guess that's where i would be
putting my attention right now when it
comes to like irresponsible deployments
it was a great question because i looked
you know when i read the question
irresponsible ai deployment definitely a
couple examples come to my mind pro
public published his article a couple
years ago about how some courts are
using uh ai to help them to make
sentencing decisions so right so how how
many years should should the defendant
get and because the the system was uh
obviously it was built off historical
historical data
discriminated against minorities so the
i system
when they spit out a result the
sentencing results also end up just
discriminating against uh minorities
whereas we have this known image of two
people similar type of offense whereas
one person the caucasian get a lot less
years than the african-american defender
and and also in the recent years we've
seen companies have used ai for
hiring hr right again used based on his
historical data either from that
particular company or from just
corporate you know world generally and
the result is you can imagine the same
type of discrimination issues so
obviously we have all those challenges
is
met because in a while i love this it's
just very visual but how do we deal with
it do we establish a
you know an agency a website or a phone
number you can call you can say this is
irresponsible yeah you the government or
someone to do something about it
i don't know whether that's the bad
solution because you know that can lead
to so many questions how do you define
responsible whose opinion and even
nowadays you know we have a by the way
at the center we have a whole iii team
so we do a lot of work which you can
check on on our website but even just to
come up with the general overall
principle set of rules for ai ethics is
still something in the making so i think
we definitely have have a long way to go
graham any additional thoughts on that
topic
i would just say i would put a plug-in
for
some of the privacy oriented rules that
rules that are made around data handling
personal information handling i'm most
familiar with the the chinese and
european examples but in each case
there's certain there are
elements of consent and autonomy that
are built in as
values and so that it's a violation to
use personal data in automated decision
making in a way that isn't that's
outside of these sort of principles that
are laid out in these regulatory systems
and i think that's a useful tool because
it empowers enforcement agencies with
something like the ftc could do it we
just don't have rules in the united
states for this type of thing where if
you lay out
some principles for how data should be
handled this is a great
hook
for regulatory schemes to essentially
give themselves
a way into
the
ethical or just used of machine learning
just because at this point the machine
learning is all heavily data-based and
if we get to instruction-based advanced
ai then
we'll have to use another hook to get in
but i think that there is
there are
data protection authorities that you can
report to in many jurisdictions around
the world about some categories of
abuses of automation and i think that
model could be
extended across beyond personal
information specifically and start
thinking about
how to
ensure things are safe but i wouldn't
want regulatory uh structures to get too
technology specific because even with
the best people trying to move back and
forth between places like silicon valley
and washington dc you're not going to
end up with
an institution like congress moving at a
speed that is rational for handling
what's coming down the line this month
let alone five years from now
it's interesting graham that you answer
this question more from a data privacy
approach since i think
some individuals will say that china
will think about leveraging facial
recognition technology to identify and
repress its minority populations or some
people have criticized china for using
ai to build a surveillance state while
from a u.s perspective especially the
report that just came out last week
there's the argument that the u.s needs
to make sure it maintains its commitment
to
international humanitarian law and human
rights and really focus on preserving
rights and liberties when using ai
i'm curious if any of you have thoughts
around if this is the two approaches
that china and u.s might be taking what
this does mean for the larger battle of
text supremacy which i know we already
talked about is not really a term we
like to use and just in general the the
commercial and national security
advantages that come with it
yeah can i just really quickly on the
question of personal information
regulation in china it's
it's absolutely right that the chinese
government is a highly intrusive
surveillance organization and that
high-tech surveillance is used in
service of the objectives including the
atrocities in xinjiang that the u.s
government and others have called
a genocide
but there's a huge distinction to be
made in terms of the way that private
companies are being regulated in the way
that they use personal data versus the
expectation of privacy vis-a-vis the
government especially concerning
security authorities so there's some
protection against misconduct by
everyday authorities in china but
they're not well enforced and national
security powers and police powers are
extremely broad and widely abused
however increasingly companies like
tencent and baidu and alibaba and all
the others are getting greater and
greater scrutiny there are more and more
rules many of them closely resembling
gdpr and then moving ahead in terms of
anticipating newer problems especially
in the chinese context there is
regulation and it's real so i think when
people talk about privacy and governance
in china around technology they
it's
you're missing part of the picture if
you don't
recognize the abuses and and if you
don't recognize the kind of increased
basically increasingly competent
regulation of the private sector when it
comes to data and of course in alignment
with the communist party and the
government's priorities never forget
that but the the separation is crucial
thanks for pointing that out matt do you
have additional thoughts on that topic
sure maybe i'll just a little bit on the
role of data
in say competition between companies or
states whatever level you want to look
at it i think with the pendulum like so
many things in our assessment of sort of
u.s china technological strengths and
weaknesses the pendulum has swung really
far back and forth on how we think about
data in these systems so i think early
on in
2016-17 when a lot of people in the
policy world in the business world are
getting woke to the power of ai and deep
learning and the first thing you learn
is that the more data is better at
training the systems so i think we
started off with this very kind of very
focused on data when talking about
competition between companies or states
and ai and the general sort of takeaway
was oh china has so many people and
nobody cares about privacy and so
there's all the data is going to eat us
all
with all their massive data i think the
reaction to that and an appropriate one
from a lot of people who think seriously
about this
was to really try to push back against
that narrative and say data's just one
piece of the ecosystem it's a lot more
complicated it's not just about how many
people are in your facial recognition
database there's a lot of other
dimensions to that i think we've pulled
uh
but there was an effort by many people
myself included some extent to just yank
the narrative back over to no it's not
so much about data it's really about
talent it's about research talent and
it's about semiconductors
in reality it's somewhere in the middle
i think denying that
the
i think that denying that china has a
benefits a lot from having uh large
pools of data and the government
benefits from having access
uh to that data via it's like security
organs and trying to deny that would be
like foolish long-term but it's also not
the deciding factor in u.s china ai
competition
i know that's a broad statement of it
but i've just i've been noticing lately
how much we've gone on these pendulum
swings with how we think about chinese
technology and i think data is one of
those maybe just one plug for
a way of thinking about
how the us and europe can compete more
effectively knowing that china has
something akin to a data advantage
there's a really interesting paper also
by the center for security and emerging
technology cset in dc and i believe it
was called shaping the terrain
of ai competition something like that
had the words shaping the terrain in
there and the big picture sort of thesis
was if we acknowledge that china maybe
has an advantage from its access to data
one way that we can mitigate that
advantage long term and preserve privacy
long term is to try to essentially push
the field of ai into more
privacy preserving directions
and i'll give two examples of that
one of them is what's called fu shot
learning which basically means being
able to train an ai system on far fewer
examples it doesn't matter whether you
have 5 000 or 5 million uh images in the
database and you can train effectively
on on the smaller number
and another example that i believe
actually first heard from graham
drinking a beer on a sidewalk in oakland
somewhere was about federated learning
which is functionally a different method
of approaching machine learning where
you do a certain amount of the
computation certain amount of the
computation needed for training an
algorithm on the sort of the edge device
and not having to essentially put all of
the uh data into sort of a centralized
cloud or a server where the training is
done and in doing that you anonymize the
data these would be the individual
people in it and so these are just two
two kind of technologies both of them
are very they're very nascent they are
not like widely used but they are
getting a lot of attention in the
research community
and
if the us through us and europe through
essentially funding research in these
areas through having our companies adopt
those techniques
is able to shift the broader field of
machine learning in a privacy preserving
direction in a direction that minimizes
the impact of data in that context that
would be a long-term
shift that would take some advantage
away from china in this competition and
just would take advantage away from big
tech companies that might like to
exploit this whether at home or abroad
so
i had some other point but that's just
about it i think
i do want to turn it over to some
questions that popped up from the class
so the first question is do you think
the technological developments employed
elsewhere in china will be adopted by
the west i'll let the student who asks
that question also provide any
additional comment yeah thank you all
very much for today i was in xinjiang in
and i had a driving chinese driving
license i was able to drive around
and
what was the overwhelming
feeling was as i was pulled over many
times
and then interrogated in different
control centers was the vast levels of
surveillance and i think we briefly
touched upon this i wonder whether you
see a day-to-day life
in the west that replicates
that level of surveillance and i think
you touched upon it but i think i'm
quite interested in
the the day-to-day norms
of what i saw in xinjiang and whether
that could ever foreseeably be
replicated
in the west
so i can react first and see if others
have something because i've thought
about this to a fairly deep degree
from time to time
for a couple of reasons and so first of
all i think essentially no i don't think
we're going you know i don't think
oakland is turning into xinjiang we have
we've banned facial recognition by use
by the government in in the city of
oakland overall that's it's things are
moving in the opposite direction but the
other thing to say about it is that
there's because one of the ways that i
think about it is the u.s and i think
some others have
moved to sanction some key chinese
surveillance technology companies
especially those that make facial
recognition enabled
cameras
over specifically for their involvement
in the abuses in xinjiang and for sort
of enabling this and i as a policy
question i've so i keep questioning did
this really accomplish anything i don't
really object to it from a perspective
of yes these companies are they do
profit from this this sector of their uh
customer base
but is it helping the people at the
receiving end of the human rights abuses
and my hypothesis would be that in large
part no it's not because the main policy
the main sort of driver of the brutality
and the misery and the abuses is the
chinese government's policy decision to
essentially try to eliminate the
distinctiveness of uyghurs and other
muslims and to bring xinjiang under
control
and that decision is being pursued using
available technologies including facial
recognition which are not at all
uniquely available from chinese vendors
of course american vendors israeli
vendors others around the world and i
went through enough of a deep learning
coursera to to realize that if you have
enough compute and much better skills
than i do that facial recognition isn't
like a super hard problem anymore i
don't think it's coming for all of us
but i do think that capability is going
to be much more widely distributed
around the world and so where you have
governments that want to be that
intrusive or that dominating they will
reach for this tool among others but
it's that's the question is whether
whether the brutality is being advanced
because you could have a place like
london which is super highly surveilled
that
with all the civil there are real civil
liberty problems in the uk and the
police and national security powers have
been abused from time to time according
to people like me who are real privacy
advocates but it's not xinjiang but
camera coverage is similar
another question from the class is in
this global race for tech supremacy
particularly u.s china is it an issue
for the us that it knows less about
what's going on in china than the
reverse if so what can and should the us
do about that all the students who ask
that question provide any additional
comments
yeah hi everyone thanks so much for your
time that's why i listed the question
and
part of the reason why i did that was
because from my time working in silicon
valley and also in beijing i realized
that especially a few years ago everyone
in china they were studying how google
works how facebook works i think they
i think they know a lot about what's
going on in the u.s whether it's in dc
new york silicon valley i think to the
extent that i think a lot of people in
china now feel like they've learned
enough and they don't even have to learn
about it anymore whereas i think in the
us it's i think a lot of people still
don't maybe other than the panelists
here so you don't know too much about
what's going on there so i think maybe
to the point of uh
first mover advantage that you were
talking about i think
many people in china are like on the in
the tech field they're able to just
learn from what's going on in the u.s
and then try to do even better so i was
wondering like what should be the u.s
response to this whole information
asymmetry i think
david you obviously hit the nail on the
head there's a huge information
asymmetry and it's a huge problem and i
think that's a lot of what like graham
does at digit china is very much trying
to fill in that gap with translation and
analysis a lot of what i do is trying to
fill in that gap as well
i think in terms of like policy
prescriptions that the government
is doing a lot more embracing of open
source intelligence ocint
which is something that the chinese
government tends to be very good at
leveraging
and there i'm talking about the chinese
government the us government i'm talking
about the word you know intelligence so
it sounds very much like a sort of
military matter but i i understand that
what you're talking about is often just
a more
it's low-key it's people in beijing
reading whatever wired or whatever is
the like latest publication whereas
americans in the similar sector not
reading the same in chinese but i do
think there is a lot of there's like a
lot of low-hanging fruit in terms of
open source intelligence particularly in
ai and ai research
because it is such a open by default
field people when papers are
written they're immediately published
online at the site called archive and it
makes it relatively easy to track the
kind of trends in research developments
particularly much more than sort of
private sector like business model
trends but yeah it makes it easier this
is a lot of the work that i've done the
last past few years is looking at
top-tier researchers in the us and china
and globally and how do they move
between different countries and based on
that entirely on on totally open source
online information
so i know that
this is something that yeah china has
been very good at for a while
and i think the us government is
especially
pushing on it now the the
just to point to the as the deputy of
ostp the white house office of science
technology and policy is a guy named
jason matheny who's a huge advocate of
leveraging this type of open source
intelligence for government decision
making but yeah that's not the same as
just having every entrepreneur in china
know what's going on in the valley and
having americans only catching like tiny
little tidbits that come out of china
periodically
but just two good points one so david
exactly i think everything's just
very much true at the same time in
certain industries for example in
e-commerce and in fintech i think the
so-called silicon valley is also looking
at china for some inspirations for
example on digital payments definitely
see that how social media haven't tried
to roll payments into its whole
ecosystem etc etc and two i think to
really address that problem starts with
you all of you i read this report
recently saying that i think the number
of americans you know university
students are studying about china or on
china are trying to relate topics and
the number went down quite a bit so it's
actually alarming just because u.s and
china relationship is entering such a in
a intricate period where at the same
time folks and students are studying
this are going down so that's a major
issue so the
fact that all of you here and maybe
after this talking
inspired to an hour later to go deeper
on this topic i think that's really
start with that with all of you
i would just add very briefly that i i
of course very much believe that people
need to pay more attention to china and
governments and businesses should
support programs like mine and the
projects that matt works on and etc etc
but
i do think that we also get trapped a
little bit sometimes even the people who
are trying to look at tech issues across
borders and pay attention to china and
europe and maybe india
and then that's usually it and so
there's the rest of the world out there
um and i just think it's crucial i think
both for business reasons for governance
reasons human rights reasons that
starting in universities and people who
are students and have the opportunity to
learn more languages or to intentionally
study a context that is not one of the
ones that is
flush with funding we just need as much
of that as possible and exchanges are
hard to do especially right now when we
can't travel but a plug for the rest of
the world no no joke the final question
is related to graham your point on
people need to pay more attention to
china but also europe india other parts
of the world so the question is do you
think america presents a technological
threat to the rest of the world or
should china be our only major concern
and who asked that question
yeah this was me i think there was a
slightly egregious question that was do
you think russia presents a
technological threat to the us
or china should we have any major
concern so i think i was just trying to
combat this american exceptionalism
and
centrism so slightly tongue-in-cheek but
it'd be interesting to take your
thoughts on that
i think this
i take that tongue-in-cheek question
seriously and because i think a lot of
people in other countries take it
seriously it was interesting watching
the sort of fallout when twitter and
facebook and everyone banned trump after
the capital riots
some of the people who in terms of world
leaders the people who spoke out the
most firmly against it were european
leaders who
have no love uh for trump whatsoever and
also have themselves been very hard on
u.s companies about content moderation
and saying you've got to take a harder
line on stopping extremism and
inflammatory content online but i think
those
people in other countries when they see
the u.s technology companies blocking a
current us president from their
platforms they look at their own like
digital mortality in the mirror
i think it makes them very deeply
uncomfortable the idea that a u.s
company
can fundamentally decide what happens in
terms of speech in all countries all
around the world and
that's europe probably still has a lot
of like insulation on this front because
they have a regulatory apparatus that
can do real damage and exact real sort
of costs on the us tech companies
but
historically if you were a country like
thailand and you had a high national
priority
government priority or social priority
content moderation issue or technology
issue the chances that you'd be able to
elevate that and have it taken like the
same degree of seriousness that it would
if it emerged out of the u.s and europe
is very small i think countries around
the world are slowly realizing they have
more leverage than imagined china's
pioneers this by blocking the tech
companies and just saying no screw you
we're just going to hold the line and i
think a lot of countries have slowly
learned that actually the big u.s
juggernauts are more more prone to
intimidation at losing markets than we
thought maybe 10 years ago
but still if you're a country or a
leader in a country anywhere else in the
world you do feel like your sort of
digital ecosystem is fundamentally in
the hands of a very small group of
americans
i would i agree with matt but i would
also add that i i just thought of
another way to look at it as facebook
can be a threat to regime stability in
the united states and in other countries
and
a threat to privacy all at the same time
and when we talk about what the
technological
risks and menaces are some of them are
american patterns and american companies
that perhaps could be more effectively
regulated in this country but you know
sometimes it's the companies some do a
better job than other others in being
responsive and i i'm picking on facebook
because they're
the most prominent one so they're if
there's going to be a problem they're
going to be involved in and i know that
a lot of people there are working hard
on various things but yeah so at some
point i i agree with matt that some more
governments are finding levers to hold
these companies accountable and i think
that's a good development and just
quickly there's a term part of silicon
states and saying that the tech
companies are having more and more
influence in power they reach billions
of people it was interesting couple
years ago denmark started this program
or this position called the tech
ambassador so basically just the same
level as ambassador in dc but it's
actually based here in silicon valley
and to because a lot of the issues that
influence dc they say we have ambassador
to thailand why not to here and now that
the companies that actually have
anything away
can have huge impact on
both their citizens and